wenn ihr wissen wollt wie dieses Fest
mal hier entstanden ist dann müsst ihr
einfach nur dieses Video gucken das
Beste ist ihr könnt es komplett
Nachkochen aber seid gewarnt ist ein
bisschen Arbeit deshalb fangen wir
direkt am besten an
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu diesem besonderen
Video und dem ich mein Weihnachtsmenü
für dieses Jahr koche für euch mit allen
Mengenangaben so dass ihr es komplett
Nachkochen könnt oder einfach bei dem
leckeren Essen zuschauen könnt wir haben
drei Gerichte die heute auf dem
Speiseplan stehen die allesamt wirklich
besonders sind mein Plan für dieses Menü
war es etwas zu schaffen was wirklich
ein Festessen ist alles ist auf seine
Art und Weise geschmacklich super
intensiv für zehn von zehn werden wir es
richtig machen als Vorspeise gibt es
eine Maronensuppe mit karamellisiertem
Chicoree klingt vielleicht nicht nach
viel ist aber unfassbar
geschmacksintensiv und pure
winterlichkeit und weihnachtlichkeit als
nächstes haben wir ein argentinisches
Rinderfilet reverse gegart also im Ofen
gegart perfektes Medium wäre wunderschön
rosa dazu ein Sellerie Kartoffel
trüffelpüree habt ihr bestimmt noch nie
gegessen es ist unfassbar gut eine
leckere Rotwein schalottensoße und als
krönenden Abschluss gibt es ein
Schokolade mit Espresso Mascarpone und
Spekulatius crumble
soll ich noch was sagen ist das nicht
Weihnachten ist das nicht festlich und
ich sag so viel ihr könnt das auch
deshalb gut aufpassen wir fangen an so
wie ich auch kochen werde an Weihnachten
mit dem Dessert einfach weil es dann
schon fertig ist dann hat man eine Sorge
weniger dass keinem Kühlschrank stehen
genauso machen wird das sind die Zutaten
fürs Dessert das Rezept findet ihr auch
in der Videobeschreibung aber alles was
wir heute kochen ist für 8 Personen für
große Weihnachtsfeier 300g dunkle
Schokolade die schmelzen wir über dem
Wasserbad
zack einfach in die Schüssel rein
langsam die beiden Sachen brauchen wir
erst zum Abschluss das habe ich
eigentlich immer wegstellen
Mascarpone Creme einfach nochmal als
Extra oben drauf und unsere Schokolade
brauchen wir nur noch Sahne und Eier
also bringen wir langsam die 300 Gramm
Schokolade zum Schmelzen das kann ein
bisschen Zeit brauchen aber das ist gar
nicht schlimm weil wir wollen auf jeden
Fall nicht dass sie verbrennt wir ziehen
einen Espresso auch der muss natürlich
gut sein wenn wir leckeres Espresso
musst du Schokolade machen wollen geben
davon wirklich ein kleines bisschen in
unsere Schokolade rühren das Ganze unter
bis wir eine glatte Masse haben
weiter geht's mit unserem Wasserbad wir
geben eine neue Schüssel darauf und
schlagen 8 Eier hinein die Eier sind
relativ klein wenn ihr größer habt dann
könnt ihr auch sechs benutzen und wir
verrühren Sie ganz vorsichtig wie gesagt
wichtig dass die Schüssel nicht zu heiß
ist sie sollen nicht stocken schlagen
sie schaumig und der Sinn des Ganzen ist
dass die fluffig werden aber auch das
mögliche Salmonellen absterben und wenn
die Eier so aussehen können wir sie
langsam unterrühren unter unsere Schoko
espressomassen auch hier ist ein
bisschen Kraft in den Armen gefragt
kräftig rühren bis das ganze eine
homogene Masse ergibt und ich sage euch
so viel das sieht viel versprechend aus
eine Komponente fehlt noch Schlagsahne
wenn ich süß haben wollt könnt ihr auch
noch ein bisschen Zucker hinzugeben aber
ich habe es einfach naturbelassen ich
hätte wirklich nicht gedacht dass es so
unfassbar lange dauert ein Liter Sahne
steif zu schlagen wir dachten irgendwas
stimmt nicht aber mit der Zeit hat es
dann doch funktioniert wir haben aber
locker 5 Minuten oder gefühlt 5000
Stunden gemixt das Ergebnis war am Ende
so aus vielleicht hätten wissen ein
bisschen steifer schlagen können aber
kein Problem davon nehmen wir uns jetzt
ein Drittel und heben das vorsichtig
unter die so Kaffee Einmischung
gleichmäßig integrieren wir geben die
restliche Sahne dazu heben die auch noch
unter wir haben jetzt 13:45 Uhr um 18
Uhr kommen die Gäste 13 Uhr haben wir
angefangen also 45 Minuten sind jetzt
mehr oder weniger drauf gegangen für
unser Schokolade bin ich vollkommen
Verein mit weil es wird Helm und alles
genau mit Film vor allem ne also das
heißt entweder ihr seid noch nicht so
geübt braucht ein bisschen mehr Zeit
oder ihr macht wahrscheinlich doppelt so
schnell wie wir gucken alleine mal die
Konsistenz an das ist so schaumig so
fluffig ich würde sagen das fühlen wir
ab in kleine Förmchen und dann müssen
wir noch rausholen weiter geht's mit dem
nächsten Gericht dem Star unseres Menüs
und somit das Hauptgangs ein ganzes
Rinderfilet und könnte sagen es ist ein
goldfilet weil es ein argentinisches ist
und es ist wirklich sehr prächtig sehr
groß da könnt ihr selbst gucken wie groß
das rinderfile ist welches ihr kaufen
möchte weil es gibt großes gibt kleine
so die einfach jeder auf seine Kosten
kommt so und wir wollen jetzt schauen
dass wir ein Stück vom Filet frei
stellen und von der Silberhaut befreien
das relativ gleich dick ist wenn jetzt
relativ kleines Rinderfilet habt gibt es
einen kleinen Trick könnt das auch
umklappen so dass es dann quasi dieselbe
dicke wie überall sonst auch hat wir
haben wirklich ein riesenfilet hier
liegen weshalb ich die filetspitze der
Einfachheit halber ist halt noch schöner
abtrenne daraus machen wir aber
irgendwie eine Pasta mit
rinderfiletspitzen oder so ein sauberer
Schnitt am Ende jetzt haben wir auf
einer Seite schon mal begrenzt an der
anderen Seite sehen wir den filetkopf
den wir hier haben wir müssen wir auch
einmal abtrennen ich mache das richtig
ich habe Eric hinter der Kamera der
jederzeit einschreiten kann zack
filetkopf abschneiden und jetzt haben
wir hier wirklich ein Bild hübsches
Rinderfilet rechts an manchen Teilen
dicker ist an anderen Teilen dünner ist
aber gar nicht schlimm weil wenn man
acht Gäste hat wollen bestimmt manche
medium rare die anderen wollen müssen
eher Medium mit anderen wollen sie
versteht was meine unser nächster Job
ist es die Silberhaut zu entfernen wir
befreien jetzt das gesamte Filet einmal
von der Silberhaut und dann geht's
weiter mit dem nächsten Schritt
[Musik]
hier ist die Silber und die wir entfernt
haben ich bin beim besten Willen kein
Profi aber gute Nachrichten für
diejenigen von euch die ist auch nicht
sind jeder kann das schaffen hier ist
also unser Rinderfilet es ist wirklich
bildhübsch wie es da steht wäre es jetzt
einmal leicht salzen und dann geben wir
es in den Backofen mit Rosmarin Thymian
und Knoblauch garen ist mit einem
Thermometer bis zu 47 Grad
Kerntemperatur relativ entspannt 65 Grad
im Ofen ungefähr 2 bis 3 Stunden aber
tut euch selbst den Gefallen so ein
Rinderfilet kostet ja schon so ein
kleines dünnchen kauft euch einfach für
10 € Thermometer weil sowas ohne
Thermometer zubereiten ist eigentlich
ein Verbrechen
[Musik]
also rein damit in den Ofen und wir
können uns unbesorgt um die weiteren
Schritte kümmern weil uns das
Thermometer Sicherheit gibt kommen wir
zur Vorspeise ihr merkt es ist alles
vollkommen durcheinander aber so ist das
halt wenn man für so ein großes Event
kocht wie Weihnachten deshalb kommen wir
zu den Zutaten ich habe hier ein
bisschen Butter 100 Gramm dann habe ich
eine Knoblauchzehe die ich grob
geschnitten habe hier drüben haben wir
100 Gramm Knollensellerie die habe ich
grob gewürfelt muss man nicht zu
filigran machen das Ganze wird später eh
püriert dann hier Pancetta vier dicke
Scheiben die wirklich eine gewisse Dicke
mit sich bringen könnt ihr aber auch
dörfleisch verwenden diesen Bauchspeck
der so vakuumiert im Supermarkt ist
funktioniert alles Pancetta ist
natürlich ein bisschen heller Schalotten
8 Stück an der Zeit war ein bisschen
Arbeit die alle so fein zu Würfeln aber
dadurch gehen Sie so richtig perfekt in
der Soße auf jetzt beginnen wir unsere
Arbeit indem wir 50 Gramm Butter in
unseren Topf geben und die langsam
schmelzen und dahin schmelzen die Butter
ist geschmolzen das heißt es wird Zeit
für unsere Pancetta da steckt so viel
Geschmack drin hier müssen wir ein
bisschen aufpassen die hat schon ein
bisschen Salz Pfeffer dran deshalb
müssen wir da vielleicht später
vorsichtig sein geben die mit in den
Topfen lassen sie jetzt goldbraun aus
und spätestens jetzt werden die ersten
Köpfe aus dem Zimmern gestreckt und es
wird gefragt wann es Essen gibt weil das
riecht einfach unglaublich ich meine
guckt es euch an diese kleinen Bläschen
die Farbe die entsteht die ganze Küche
nein das ganze Büro hat so geduftet
unbeschreiblich in der ausgelassenen
Chat da haben wir dann anschließend
Sellerie schalotten und Knoblauch
angebraten und das ganze mit ein
bisschen Zucker versehen das hebt die
Süße der Schalotten hervor und bringt
alles noch besser zusammen beim ersten
umrühren hat man schon direkt die
unglaubliche Farbe gesehen die die
Pancetta im Topf hinterlassen hat und
das ist wirklich einfach malerisch das
ganze ist aber normalen Suppe deshalb
brauchen wir auch Maronen die haben wir
vorher ein bisschen im Wasserbad erwärmt
außerdem vakuumiert gekauft dass er
spart einem jede Menge Kopfschmerzen so
sind sie schon geschält und direkt
verarbeitet werden fertig wenn die
Maronen warm sind geben wir sie mit in
den Topf braten Sie ein bisschen an
rühren Sie unter
schon merkt richtig wie wir Geschmack
auf Geschmack gepackt haben bei allen
bisherigen Schritten und das Endergebnis
wird es uns danken und um diese
Geschmäcker auch zusammenzubringen
löschen wir das Ganze mit einem
ordentlichen Schluck Portwein ab
wirklich ein Traum also wer mir erzählt
dass das hier nicht aussieht als würde
es krass schmecken der lügt das sieht
gerade aus wie so ein Gulasch wirklich
zu einer Suppe indem wir Gemüsebrühe
hinzugeben so wird aus unserer Masse
eine Suppe aber ein paar Gewürze dürfen
auch nicht fehlen frisch aus dem
heimischen Kräutergarten ein bisschen
Thymian bisschen Rosmarin noch ein
bisschen Thymian ja bei so einer großen
Menge sollte man auf jeden Fall ein
Gewürzen sparen so lassen wir das ganze
jetzt für 40 Minuten mit Deckel drauf
köcheln mittlere Hitze jetzt heißt es
nur noch abwarten und ich sage euch eins
es ist anstrengend aber es lohnt sich
hoffe ich zumindest an dieser Stelle
macht unsere Sellerie ein Camberg für
unser Sellerie Kartoffel trüffelpüree
die Sellerie schneiden wir dafür in
gleichförmige Würfel die dürfen ruhig
etwas gröber sein weil wir das Ganze
Peter mixen das gleiche machen wir mit
Kartoffeln und die Würfel sind dafür da
dass das Ganze gleichmäßig gart und zwar
in einem Topf mit gesalzenem kochendem
Wasser darin kochen wir das Ganze für 20
Minuten dass der Sellerie oben schwimmt
das ganz normal er ist einfach leichter
als das Wasser in einem weiteren Topf
garen wir schon mal unsere Buschbohnen
vor damit Sie später bereit für den
Speckmantel sind ihr merkt schon es geht
heiß her aber wir sind noch lange nicht
am Ende wir machen weiter mit unserer
Charlotten Rotweinsoße für unseren
Hauptgang für unser Rinderfilet dafür
befreien wir erstmal ein ganzes Netz
kleine Schalotten von ihrer Schale das
ist wirklich ein bisschen Detailarbeit
aber es sieht am Ende Bild hübsch auf
dem Teller aus weitere Zutaten für
unsere Rotwein Schalotten sind
Puderzucker Thymian Zimtstangen Anis und
Nelken als erstes schmelzen wir unseren
Puderzucker in einem kleinen Topf ich
war wirklich überrascht wie gut das
funktioniert innerhalb von Minuten haben
wir diese wunderbare goldbraune Farbe
die wir dann anschließen mit Rotwein
ablöschen können jetzt rühren wir bis
der Zucker in den Rotwein geschmolzen
ist ich habe dann noch den Portwein dazu
geschüttet und anschließend alle Zutaten
hineingegeben zuerst die Schalotten dann
Thymian Anis Nelken Zimtstangen und das
Ganze einmal umgerührt so lassen wir es
jetzt köcheln bis die gesamte
Flüssigkeit verdampft ist kartoffeln und
Sellerie haben jetzt 20 Minuten gekocht
das heißt wir können Sie abschütten
ordentlich abdampfen lassen dann in
einen Topf bei mittlerer Hitze wo wir
sie kontinuierlich wenden so dass immer
noch weiterer Dampf absteigen kann wir
wollen diese trocken wie möglich
bekommen damit unser Püree nicht so
super flüssig wird in einen kleinen Topf
geben wir 60 Gramm Butter schmelzen sie
und lassen sie braun werden während
gebräunte Butter unglaublich lecker ist
sind diese kleinen verbrannten
milchpartikel beim besten Willen nicht
deshalb filtern wir Sie durch den
Küchentuch so dass uns nur die gebräunte
Butter bleibt das ist ein kleiner
Mehraufwand der aber wirklich viel
bewirkt nachdem die Sellerie
Kartoffelmasse ungefähr 15 Minuten
abgedampft ist geben wir 600 ml Sahne
drauf die rühren wir unter und lassen
sie vorsichtig köcheln zurück zur Soße
wir schneiden eine Zwiebel in Streifen
damit wir die Soße zu unseren Rotwein
Schalotten machen können dazu gehen wir
zur nächsten bisschen Zucker in einen
Topf und karamellisieren ihn wenn er
braun und flüssig ist geben wir die
Zwiebeln drauf und löschen auch Ihnen
mit Rotwein ab jetzt kann man etwas
Masala dazu dann geben wir noch
Rinderbrühe dazu und investieren das
ganze auf ein Drittel der Flüssigkeit
unser Püree ist zwischenzeitlich
eingedickt und bereit für die nächsten
Schritte dazu habe ich mir ein
hochleistungsmixer gepackt das
funktioniert super sonst tut es aber
auch einen Stabmixer je feiner das Püree
am Ende wird desto besser etwas
Cayennepfeffer und die gebrannte Butter
dazu und einmal gut durchmixen schaut
euch an wie gerade alles vereint wird
und wir am Ende ein wunderbar cremiges
glattes Püree haben jetzt geht's noch
ans geschmackliche Feintuning ein guter
Esslöffel Trüffelbutter der das noch mal
aufs nächste Level hebt ein bisschen
Salz ein letztes Mal durch pürieren und
fertig ist unser Sellerie Kartoffelpüree
auch unsere Soße ist fast fertig wir
befinden uns auf der Zielgeraden wir
schütten die Soße durch den Sieb so dass
die Zwiebeln zurück bleiben und geben
die gefilterte Soße in einen Topf jetzt
durch ein bisschen Speisestärke mit
Rinderbrühe an und dicke die Soße ein
habe da wirklich ein bisschen Geduld und
wartet ab bevor die Soße zu dick macht
die Schalotten kommen dazu und fertig
ist die Soße die Gäste sind gerade
angekommen deshalb muss ich schnell die
Maronensuppe fertig machen ziehen sie
dafür einmal mit dem Stabmixer durch
schmeckt sie mit Trüffelöl es gibt noch
ein bisschen Balsamico dazu den ich
einrühre und wir machen das Topic
Chicoree fein hacken in geschmolzener
Butter mit etwas Zucker karamellisieren
und leicht dünsten um das Ganze
abzulöschen benötigen wir Orangensaft
und natürlich habe ich ihn frisch
gepresst 300 ml um genau zu sein die ich
dann anschließend auf den Chicoree gebe
und ein wenig einkochen lasse vielleicht
habt ihr diese vor lauter Action
vergessen aber wir kümmern uns um die
Boden wir schneiden oben und unten ein
bisschen ab und wickeln Sie mit ein
bisschen Pancetta ein wenn wir unsere
Pakete geschnürt haben braten wir sie
ein bisschen Butter an so dass der Bacon
schön braun wird ein bisschen Farbe
bekommt sieht das nicht wunderbar aus
unser Rinderfilet auf jeden Fall auch
nach drei Stunden hat sich auch an der
Oberfläche ein bisschen was getan aber
um die Kruste kümmern wir uns jetzt
Butterschmalz auf der planscher warm
machen du musst also eine Pfanne tut's
auch und scharf anbraten von allen
Seiten jetzt geht's wirklich nur darum
eine Kruste daran zu bekommen innen drin
ist das Fleisch schon perfekt das medium
rare deshalb richtig heiß und richtig
kurz ruhen lassen und ich war wirklich
froh dass es geschafft war wenn ihr bis
jetzt mitgekocht habt dann fühle ich auf
jeden Fall euren Schmerz weil es war
kein leichter Weg aber bisher hat alles
ganz gut geklappt deshalb servieren wir
jetzt endlich heiße Maronensuppe kommt
in unsere Teller und garniert wird das
Ganze das ist schon relativ viel was wir
ein wenig karamellisiertem Chicoree
einfach so schön in die Mitte hinein
gibt ein farblichen Kontrast schmeckt
auch noch sehr viel und so machen wir
das jetzt mit acht Tellern und Fasan war
plötzlich eine voll ausgewachsene
Weihnachtsfeier im Gange das hat
eigentlich nur als kochvideo gestartet
aber wir saßen gemeinsam am Tisch hatten
eine gute Zeit haben ein bisschen was
getrunken wirklich jeder fand alles sehr
lecker was nicht glücklich gemacht hat
und wenn ihr das nachkocht dann werdet
ihr im schönes Weihnachtsfest haben für
einen kurzen Moment war sogar die ganze
Arbeit vergessen was für ein Menü was
für ein Tag was für ein mit Koch
Eskalation es hat sich aber wirklich
gelohnt finde ich weil es hat alles
richtig gemacht was ein Weihnachtsmenü
machen muss deshalb ein ausgemacht das
hat ultra intensiv geschmeckt es war
kräftig war so dass man jetzt einfach
schlafen möchte und einen großen Bogen
um die Küche da drüben machen will das
werde ich jetzt vielleicht auch tun wie
auch immer falls ihr es Nachkochen
werdet wünsche ich euch ganz viel Spaß
dabei fühl mich wirklich das muss jetzt
schlafen gehen und ich glaube kleine
Pause habe ich mir verdient bis zum
nächsten Mal ich wünsche natürlich allen
frohe Weihnachten die Weihnachten feiern
und hier ist ein kleines Geschenk von
mir an euch nämlich einen einfach an
Dich ein für dich vorgeschlagenes Video
darunter kannst du den Kanal abonnieren
bis dann ciao
los geht's